we are celebrating back to school all
week here on las vegas now and rocky is
live at las vegas first and only play
working space for parents and children
to learn how they can help you and your
family this school year hey rocky
hey you guys yeah okay as you can see
we've got the ball pin back here we've
got parents working over there and
before i get to what the kids are doing
in this space i want to quickly mention
i took a little tour during the break
and i noticed the zoom booths can you
please just explain that because this is
so cool yeah so there are uh telephone
booths where you can go in and take a
private zoom call or a phone call and
have some privacy and not be overheard
right and they're sound proof all of
that it just looks really cool in there
so you got to come by and just at least
see the space so you know that it's
perfect for you and your kids which have
to be two months to five years old that
is correct all right noted so let's talk
about the enrichment program that you
guys work from okay it is a waldorf
enrichment program so we have a
curriculum where it is uh arts based so
we incorporate the arts throughout all
of their curriculum and um
yeah they get to take a paint class
free play they also take yoga and dance
oh wow that is great and do you have any
obviously you created this beautiful
space um from being inspired by your own
home life is there any advice that you
have for parents at home who are working
remotely but you know are having trouble
creating a space for their kids to be
successful in as well absolutely so i
would say having a plan first of all is
a really good thing
a yoga class you can actually even take
a little break and do a yoga class
together and then give them a little
activity some arts and crafts to work on
while you get a little bit of work done
okay i like that i like that and now i
think i i can't be in here and not talk
to the kids right so come over here
girls can you just tell me what you love
most about skyluna
i really like skyluna because it's very
artistic in here and everything in here
is kid friendly i love that what about
you
it's very fun
and playful and everything
wow okay that was beautiful how does
that make you feel this is your grand
opening this is a brand new space here
at town square and the kids are already
loving it honestly it really warms my
heart because this is exactly what this
was made for
i think it's something that las vegas
really really needed not only for the
kids but also for the parents definitely
well everybody can thrive here at sky
luna so come on down you guys can take a
tour if you come through it's here at
town square conveniently located for you
and the babies okay i'll send it back to
you